going through this so
you you said a lot of different things
so this is this has been this has been
ingrained it's in your dna you've been
wired you
felt the fear and the anxiety angst uh
communism creates control creates losing
your freedom creates do you think
america
is as paranoid today you know how they
say only the paranoid survive do you
think america is as paranoid today
as they used to be uh years ago where
they treated enemies in a different way
are we a little bit more cocky loose
uh you know arrogant and you know a
little bit too much of let's share all
our secrets with the world and
everything we're doing and you think you
think we're still in that paranoid mind
where we're worried about the enemy like
before are we a little bit more looser
today
i don't think the united states has ever
been paranoid uh i think the a great
and that that frankly uh is perhaps one
of the things that threatens our our
very existence
i and i think the thing that makes the
world so dangerous is uh
between the free world and the
totalitarian
dictatorships that we face today
there's a broad gulf not just in terms
of freedom but in terms of strategic
culture
countries like russia north korea
iran
you know china
are
their strategic cultures that are
are are paranoid
genuinely paranoid uh so that they see
threats that don't even exist
and so they're willing to overreact and
over prepare
and uh and strike out
against threats that are fantasies
in their minds we're just the opposite
our civilization is what i would call
dysfunctionally optimistic
you know we think that everybody loves
us or we want the rest of the world to
love us we think that the rest of the
world understands that we're not the
aggressors we don't do pearl harbors
uh you know we this this flows from the
nature of the civilizations i should
provide some clarification why is it
that these totalitarian states and
military dictatorships think this way
and have these perceptions that's
because
you know internally
you know the
political power comes out of the barrel
of a gun for them most of their leaders
have murdered their way to the top they
have constitutions and laws that are
fake
uh you know that are just intended to
uh increase the totalitarian power of
the state over their people
it's
they don't the way they operate
internally is not through negotiation
and compromise and contracts and the
rule of law they operate uh the way
uh
criminal gangs operate and uh in the end
uh you know it's the survival of the
fittest it's might makes right uh
there's the
it's a zero-sum game it's not a win-win
kind of an outcome uh there's the living
and the dead
and that's how it operates within places
like russia china north korea and iran
and so they project their
experience in the domestic hells that
they've created onto the world stage and
they figure everybody else is like that
so they um you know and that's how the
world operates for us it's just the
opposite our domestic society
believes in win-win outcomes we try to
negotiate differences
we try to we have contracts in the rule
of law we believe in fair play
uh
and uh
and we think though and we think the
rest of the world is like that or
and this is manifest for example and the
numerous arms control treaties that
we've signed with the soviet union and
now russia over the years and we never
seem to learn you know they violate ev
all every one of them and uh and and we
never seem to learn that for them these
contracts are not binding you know uh
you know that they're willing to cheat
on them
because they don't believe in something
we have
i guess a manifestation of this thing is
is in our view in our in our culture on
our civilizational culture we believe in
this thing called peace for example
there's a condition of peace and then
there's war whereas for these other
civilizations there is only in war you
know there's war within the society to
stay in power
you're constantly at war with the other
side even though even though we call it
peace
it's really from their perspective uh
the early moves in the chess game you're
moving the pawns during the period of
peace but you're really at war and
you're getting ready for the war that's
going to come
and uh uh this makes us extremely
vulnerable that is why we are constantly
taken by surprise in the wars that we
end up get engaging in because we fail
to understand that other civilization
one of my jobs at the
cia when i worked there was to
understand the threat perceptions uh of
the other side what is their military
doctrine how do they think we could get
into a nuclear war how did they think
p that's not an easy thing to do it's
one of the hardest things to do to stand
outside of your civilization try to put
yourself in the mind
of your adversary and we don't do that
well
uh uh you know
and
so you've got
uh the worst possible combination here
when it comes to the
clash of civilizations you know a
totalitarian civilization that's
extremely paranoid sees threats
everywhere is ready to strike out
and extremely naive dysfunctionally
optimistic thinking
that we can solve any problem that
nobody sees us as a threat and that
actions that we take will not be
perceived as existential threats to our
adversaries that they understand we're
not going to attack them
it's the deadliest combination you can
have
for getting into a world war so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]